It turns out that standard deviation of distribution is not dependent on the sample,
so whether you throw a coin 100 times or a 1000 times when you graph the outcomes
the standard deviation is not affected by the sample size but the confidence interval is.
That's a really important difference.
If there's one thing you want to take home from this class that is that as you get more data as a statistician,
your confidence increases--so your confidence interval shrinks,
whereas of course more data doesn't change the standard deviation.
In fact, if the standard deviation is σ, then the confidence interval is effectively 1/√Nσ.
This is proportional, depends on number of other factors. There could be a constant in front of it.
But there is an interesting relationship.
As you get more data, the standard deviation will become more accurate,
but it's not going to change that much.
Your confidence will shrink, and we're going to look into this a more detail.